we are with Karissa in the studio after
another brilliant Victory backtack
victories for you Karissa first of all
congratulations but I mean you took a
lot of risks with that opening Choice
who advised you to do so or are you just
feeling in good shape ready to battle at
each and every
corner um I mean yeah King Kings Indian
is sort of like my go-to almost I feel
that uh I know it pretty well I've been
playing it almost since I started
playing chess um so I felt it was a good
weapon to use against Alice um obviously
she's looking for a win as well I felt
so it would be a double-edged game but I
thought I would have the edge and like
the structures and such tell us a bit
about this idea of
H6 um yeah so I think H6 is pretty
trendy these days and I didn't look
super deeply into it but the whole whole
idea is sort of like you know avoids
like Bishop E3 cuz then there's Knight
G4 no Bishop G5 in some lines the Knight
can go to age7 as well and I thought
this one was especially good because in
all of her games in database Alice
really likes this bishop E3 move so to
sort of stop it right here I thought
would be uh practically a good choice
playing against her style as
well yes that makes a lot of sense cool
and you guys got to this position and it
felt like you did everything you wanted
you got your attack going on the queen
side and on the contrary she didn't get
her attack going and her expansion going
on the queen side so it felt like you
were definitely in a driver seat but
then you decided to sacrifice the pawn
and she took it the problem with her
situation was that she only had 17
minutes against more than an hour for
you did that play into this decision to
sacrifice a pawn and uh go all in for
the
attack yeah for sure so I thought what
she was doing is kind of odd with like
this bishop G4 Bishop H3 idea um and she
could have also taken the pawn the move
before I think this is better for white
actually but I was I was evaluting a
position and like around here as well
you know and I sort of thought like this
idea that I have in the game with F4 um
trading off my bad bishop and then kind
of removing one of White's Defenders
from the King side as well the bishop on
H3 um and I just have these two files
and I thought this was better than
playing like let's say F4 immediately
without allowing taking on H6 because U
maybe White's Bishop could be helpful in
the defense or um and like my Bishop
served in the way of like the files I
want to get on to so I felt that the
sacrifice was good I felt that she was
long time and it would be like sort of
hard to play yep and but she wasend she
defended very well right and this was a
critical moment when she played G4 you
were blitzing out her moves playing in
her time travel situation but this move
G4 it stopped you for a second you
started realizing that things are not
that
easy I'm going to be honest I was I
thought she was going to play Knight
takes G3 I'm not sure why I just uh
after H takes G3 Rick H6 I missed there
was like this Rick G2 idea um so after
Knight takes G3 I was trying to sort of
take a moment to valid position after H
takes G3 I was surprised but I still
want to keep playing kind of quickly
because I felt I'd given her lot time to
think you had
to yes and you know she's just up a pond
so she can consolidate then um it'll be
okay for her and then this was the start
of her d for this move G4 just opening
the king a bit too
much yes I felt after taking on F6
Black's already I mean White's already
sort of struggling a bit and I thought
maybe like you know King G1 is a move to
play a king E2 runs into like E4 and
stuff right yeah
but um yeah it's a nice tactic so yeah I
felt pretty good about my situation here
G4 Queen H3 Rook G3 um and this is
perhaps what she miss right if you take
shirt this is a Checkmate very nice but
you just simply get ready to do that
with King to G7 yeah exactly and then
all of her pieces can't uh protect each
other properly so I have this nice takes
F3 combination Carissa excellent play
excellent attacking chess your brand of
Chess uh tell us how you feel about your
chances are you starting to dream about
potentially another
championship um I'm trying not to think
think too far ahead but I feel pretty
good about my
situation um you know I felt getting
black against Arena round one was a
little tough but I managed to survive
that and then Alice too is definitely a
really big competitor in this tournament
so I was I'm really happy about this
win congratulations uh Karissa we'll see
you tomorrow absolutely our
congratulations to you as well Carissa
is the time trouble